I'm sorry, no, no, no, very good English, right?
I'm just saying body.
Only body.
Body.
Uh,
mama.
Uh, mama.
Uh, uh, self-show-hi.
Hi.
Introduction.
Okay, introduce.
Okay.
Hello, everyone.
Hi everyone, Aibu.
I'm Ayami, illustrator and boytuber and me to Mama.
Yay!
Thank you.
I'm tired.
You have been working very hard.
Yes, early morning here.
Early morning.
Good.
Everybody, thank Ayami Mama for working so hard and being
here so early.
Oh, thank you.
I'm okay because...
Oh, so...
Minto-chan got to call me
Mint...
Mint don't invite me, Mint Channel, and I'm lonely.
But today, I'm really happy.
Yes.
We are good relationship, don't worry.
Right?
I hope so.
Yes.
No.
I respond to messages.
Yes, one month has to end.
Please.
I sent a message, a discord, but she answered in off-kai.
Off-kai?
Real meeting and, oh mama!
How dare you?
Yes, sir.
What?
The...
My mama gave me some...
Kind of...
But off-kai, I had for breakfast.
It was so delicious.
There is no breakfast.
Oh, but with coffee or coffee?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh.
Maybe, maybe fancy.
Oh, fancy morning routine.
Fancy.
I mean, not yet to eat your cherry chocolate because.
You know, I have some allergy cherry.
There was a lot of cherry.
There was a lot of cherry allergy, but...
Recently, an allergy to the cure?
An allergy to the cure, what's in English?
I don't know.
Fix allergy.
I am in hospital.
You can do?
Yeah, maybe.
Try.
try one time in Japan and I think a second time using your
cherry chocolate after Komike
but I really want to try cherry because I really I like
cherry and good for my uh childhood time uh 90 90 years old
years old 90 years past yeah 90 years and mine well it's
okay but getting older i am 100 years old uh uh cherry
allergy coming but but not not too hard i think this time
because i spent money for my body Buddy.
Next time I will bring you a different gift.
Another cherry?
No!
Please bring!
It's okay.
I can call ambulance.
It's like I'm poisoning you.
Kill me!
You are 100 years young.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you for today.
And try to use English.
But English is not...
Oh, sorry.
Now your English is perfect, right, everybody?
Woo-hoo!
Yeah!
And today is a special day.
Oh,
sorry, sorry.
I mean, bother you, sorry.
Special day, why?
Why special day?
It's, I feel, I feel you should announce because it's your,
you, you did all the work.
work I saw you could yes yes you guys know yes this is my
drawing but I mean just drawing everything design or make
goods or taking merch is comic-care official do that and i
mean just drawing and this time a big site service big site
service uh yes they they're they they day they day they that
they're doing english i don't know they're preparing
everything and design everything and i think really cute and
lovely things so many we have we can have maybe and i'm very
proud and first time it's okay first time cold day rainy
japan tokyo day i mean pms almost six jst i mean a call to
mint can i can i drawing you with me You remember?
I remember.
It was...
Yeah, Ayami called me to ask about this.
I was...
Yeah.
There is really...
Mezirashi?
Like rare.
A rare time because Ayami don't call to meet because she
didn't...
Didn't pick my...
My...
My Discord.
She didn't answer to my Discord.
and I'm really nervous but there is a really hurry ASAP yes
thing and I'm called to her but rare she picked my my call
and why mama oh you you're live thank you but it is very
rare for you to call yes because it I didn't go.
I thought like there's an accident.
Finally, she dead?
I mean, I mean just, can I draw it?
I mean, yes.
Okay, done.
Do, do, do.
Yeah, do, do, do.
Really short, short about, yeah.
I'm really happy.
I mean to say yes.
I mean to always say yes, everything.
I.
it was so happy this is so i guess we should say you know my
that ayami mama was chosen as the illustrator for komek
summer komek this year wow and everybody every otaku knows
komek is the otaku event of the year oh yeah and yeah so
when she called me and she said that she wanted to include
me in the illustration how could why would i say no maybe
sometimes your feeling is not good at oh no no i don't want
to maybe never yeah i'm really happy and i got me to answer
and i'm asking to um big site service and uh comic can i
draw in ayami and mint they are saying yes of course and
okay i can draw it uh i'm really happy to drawing this
illustration but i'm i'm nervous you know because this uh
illustration comic for comic i mean imagine is original is
your new outfit
Mint New Outfit Reveal delayed after Comic Killer?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, maybe, maybe.
Maybe sometimes happened, isn't it?
Maybe, ah, so maybe.
It was...
It made me scary.
I'm really scary, yeah.
Doki Doki, but this time...
Ah, this time, I think you guys really like Mint's New
Outfit.
Summer, not by after sundress.
I really like to, I really want to draw this sundress.
I really want to draw this sundress.
It's like a sailor, sailor-hook-hook.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
It's you.
No!
yeah it's a little it's a little similar to my dress it's
but it's it's so it's so summer yeah you remember first time
we talk about your new outfit oh that time we drawing
something something say so no school uniform oh yeah yeah I
remember Oh, yeah.
Uh, really?
Uh, it was, uh, you, I remember you post on fan box.
Oh, hi.
You stalking me?
Oh, no, oh, no.
You don't, don't follow my fan box because if you got 100,
100,000, oh, uh, 100,000.
Oh, uh, one million.
million uh one million subscriber a subscribe you got you
get so that day i will draw your read illustration and post
on fanbox please uh please don't follow my fanbox if i get
to one million i will i will unsubscribe from fanbox okay
I can not draw in, read things anymore.
Please, please, Amelia, when I am a young time.
Please, thank you, everyone.
I'll do my best.
Okay.
You do your best, really.
Amazing.
At this time of Kai, really.
You know?
Almost every artist Ellie have had?
Had?
Had your merch.
You know?
I don't know.
No, you know!
I mean, really work around artist Ellie.
Wow, everything is really cute.
I mean, don't have money because dollar...
it's too expensive this is a yen a Japan yen and it's cheap
so cheap yes I cannot buy everything oh I'm sad they're
really really impressed and really happy I am so many means
in there you're really popular and everyone love loves you
and I'm really happy but me too sometimes hate I am No,
never, never, never.
But it's okay.
I'm mama and sometimes mama and daughter of fight.
I'm going through puberty.
How was the illustration?
You like this?
Yes!
It's so cute!
I think I'm excited for it to have it on the water bottle.
So you guys...
So as Ayami Mama is the chosen illustrator for this year's
Summer Comicae, her illustration will be featured on a
collab drink.
right so you can go and get like a sports drink from the
vending machine yeah you are going to summer but but that is
a real sports drink that is maybe mean to taste water maybe
is it water your maybe your bath water maybe is that why you
asked me for my bath water inside inside the butter uh mint
water and dangerous dangerous taste maybe oh i don't think
it's sports drink scary taste maybe oh please try but who
coming i boo coming i think i told i mean before stream yeah
after she told me about this i was like you guys should come
to summer comic-cat this year i think it's gonna be good and
people in chat said too hot how dare you guys
i know definitely uh too hot and too sweat and too something
smash but but that That is real summer is real Comike, I
think.
That's true.
Yeah, that experience is real Comike.
Come.
Come, Comike.
Yes, yes, if you can come, then we would love to see you get
all the special goods.
All the special goods.
Do you want to show the goods?
yes yes five okay but also if you are not going to comic I
have I will maybe stick around chat maybe maybe something
something something okay the goods good then then wow holy
Oi!
So many things!
Yes!
I'm really shocked too.
I don't know.
I mean, last year, a few years ago, I mean, I know the big
site service make goods, but I'm shy because using my
illustration and making make too many merch.
Too many?
I mean trying to do my best but I'm shy and I think my
feeling is more to my best is more good to make this march
and I'm...
I think it's all so cute.
You've tried really hard and everything looks so good.
Wow, wow, so many things.
So we can look, we can look.
Yes, yes.
Wow, the drinks.
Drink.
Drink, yes.
Not bath water.
This is best water.
I mean, always try to...
Not, I mean, prepare my space, my booth.
After 2 p.m.
3 p.m., I mean, want to buy for if you want to drink so
everything is sold out and i cannot i cannot buy every time
but this time i don't know i don't know please drink drink
everything drink drink drink drink this is a specifically if
you get a four bottle set you can get some sticker present
yes yes yes yes it's so cute actually i saved my water
bottles so i will have i will save these
i'm really nervous I still haven't seen it yet.
I hope so.
Okay.
Tapestry!
Oh yeah.
Oh!
I hope so.
Oh okay.
Tapestry!
It's so cute!
What?
English.
Japanese.
Beautiful.
What is that?
See?
Oh, like a scenery.
Oh, yeah, scenery.
What is that?
Keshiki!
Yes, yes, yes.
Blipple scenery tightly stacked.
Don't be scary, guys.
No, look and you have a big sight.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Iconic, do you know?
As, Iconic.
Yeah, big sight is iconic.
Yes!
Otaku's iconic.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes.
It's a pilgrimage spot.
Minto, you're big sight.
You know, you know everything big sight, isn't it?
No, no, no.
Not yet?
Not yet.
I cannot believe you're really otaku than me.
I think you know more big sight than me.
No, no, no, no.
know your booth yes my booth and toilet where toilet i know
you know okay when i need to go i will ask you okay i i i'm
bring to you uh bring you to toilet okay don't worry okay
good oh the tapestry so cute yeah thank you full graphic
t-shirt T-shirt!
I cannot believe.
Meet and I meet together in T-shirt.
So cute!
Actually, everybody also is going to be at Komake because
you drew Aibu bag.
Don't!
So everybody also I'm in watching the stream will be at
Comiket too.
Please come and buy, yes.
This color, I think the designer really think about us.
And this color, the summer, like summer and like,
A really good blue designer pick up and I already, I waste
someone wearing these t-shirts and please come to my space
or walk around the Comike.
That is really, I appreciate.
Yeah!
Please try it!
Yeah, I think the designer picked a blue that kind of
matched my mint and Ayami's pink.
Yes, yes.
It looks so good!
I can't.
I can't wait to buy it.
Are you buying?
You wearing?
Yes.
You can do... do... do... yes.
Oh my god.
Are we tech potter?
Are we stalking you?
Next.
Acquiry Sando!
acrylic
stack see see
see see see
like a what's the word, oh like the holy ah like chinent
yeah the holy Holy Spot.
Yes.
Yeah, holy, uh, holy power spot.
The power spot.
Wait you.
Because, careful.
Because, care.
It's the designer's son, isn't it?
Come on.
се, I was like, oh, yeah, it's...
It's, it's, it's, it's really, it's a good thing.
Like, like, some, like, we, like, us, what, like, we, like,
us, what, like, me, like, so, like, like, a, like, well, but
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh this is pressure pressure don't make
these titles i'm shy it is a powerful a powerful title yes
yes yes yes already thank you for She's shy.
They have a lot of...
They believe in you.
Oh, yeah.
Sweeto Vint, this logo?
Oh.
This is what I'm using.
This is the best with you.
With you.
Oh, this is what I made.
Oh, you made.
Oh, that's good.
Oh, yeah.
I want to use Ski.
I want to use that word and I'm thinking about what is good,
what is good.
But this is Ski, I mean like you.
I think you like Ayami and Ibu like you and my boyfriend
like me.
We like our fans.
I'm like Comique.
Everyone, Sonander Soccer, like Soccer.
Like Soccer.
Like Soccer forever.
Maybeus, like, like, like, like, like, Comique, like
Comique, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like,
like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like,
like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like,
Yeah.
So you can do it.
You really good English.
Don't worry.
You really good.
I think I forget English and Japanese.
Yeah.
Give up?
I give up.
Oh, no.
Sorry.
Oh, like a sucker.
Like a sucker.
That's all I can remember.
Sorry.
No, no.
I think it's a really good title.
I think it's, yeah, it's, it's not just, it's not just me
and Aibu and Ayami and boyfriend.
It's all everybody who is Otaku and loves Comic-Cat
together.
And we will have the best time together.
We are the one.
What does that mean?
Yes, yes.
Otaku is one.
Otaku unite.
Yes, yes, yes.
English.
Are you okay?
Your English is getting suck or?
Yeah, I...
Please meet someone and please use English.
Yeah, I must practice my English, everybody.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, it's okay.
Your English is perfect.
It's okay.
So I think I saw some people saying, but this is the 50th
comic.
Yes, this is the 50th.
50th.
Wow.
It's a big honor.
Yeah, really happy.
We are on our illustration.
We do the 50 mark together.
is really good and happy and I'm shy.
I'm shy forever.
Oh my god, please kill me.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, yes, yes.
Next.
We have many things, yes.
Ah, coasters.
Coasters.
Double coaster.
Cute, so cute.
Do you know?
We don't know if it's acrylic or rubber.
No.
Uh, uh, uh, I don't know.
That's okay.
Uh, but please buy.
Kacha, kacha, kacha, kacha kacha, kacha, kacha, kacha, kacha
Ah, gonna drink so the new one bottle 250 yen wow so cheap
wow how dare you dollar dollar girl
yes it's so everybody will buy ice chill yeah 250 250 250
yen that to say that you can buy 10.
oh yes time and drink and go to toilet you can do it buy
more yes it's really hard and water drink is important in
comic care and please buying many things many and many
butter thank you butter and then also you can buy 24.
can you bring You can buy online online online online
shopping online shopping is is is you can buy and this
carton this box yes i'm drawing something and i mean
Yeah, I mean,
you can drink 24 is easy.
One day.
So hydrated.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
What is anti- Netu Shou, Netu Shou?
Netu Shou.
It'll become the opposite of heat stroke.
Scary things.
But if you get the 24 case, it also comes with a poster.
Yes.
And the box.
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
Oh, this is just about the bottles again.
okay the special the special stuff for comique next next
oh but i mean check a big site service uh make something
some sweets and uh and I know but this time I don't know we
have chiffon cake.
Chiffon cake!
Sugoi!
And it's soft cream.
Yes, yes, yes.
What?
So soft cream...
Do you know what taste?
Soft cream-aji no cake.
Have you ever?
No.
I'm nervous.
What taste?
I want to try.
Look you guys are cake.
Please try.
Eat.
Soft cream tastes.
Shippen cake and drink.
Meat water.
That's a healthy meal.
Oh yeah.
You get power around every comic space.
Do try, try it.
Yes, yes, yes.
So,
I'm really like sweets and I'm really looking forward to it.
Well, I really like sweets and I'm really looking forward to
it.
what is this me too me too yes yes we share oh yeah oh yeah
nine nine oh yeah so we can share
we'll have to we'll have to rock paper scissors for the last
one since there's only those nine pieces
I will buy more of these though.
Reach!
Dollar dollar girl.
This is so...
This is a shoulder bag you guys.
Look how cool.
I think this is really fancy item or attack fancy item.
This is really hard for you to know me to go.
Shorter bag is really easy for...
For, uh, what's it?
Oh, I got it.
Oh, that's it.
So, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, oh, yeah.
Like, oh, yeah.
So, it's so, it's really easy.
Comique, it's, like, event,
It's very convenient to pay at events with a bag like this.
Yes, pay, convenience, pay.
You can buy everything.
I always use shoulder bags.
What kind of you meet buying merch?
Jackie!
At...
That's scary.
Yes, I heard you make money and spend every money for...
Not every for Jackie.
I heard...
I heard you...
You...
I've no...
No...
You moving?
Oh, yes, yes.
Oh, yes.
I think it really...
no money and she moving dangerous dangerous place maybe
inside inside the mountain or somewhere nearby river or
how is that dangerous she buying so many checky um i'm
worried you you yeah i'm sometimes i mean really think about
you you're really busy you do you no no you your life she's
calling me poor that i moved to i moved to the countryside
because i have no money yeah i'm sometimes worried really
she can connect internet oh my god
actually i have cows they give they move in a circle and
they make energy for my computer oh that that's so good oh
yes um scary okay and next is what what what next is
stanley tumbler comic kid
This is really amazing.
Yeah, the 50th comic kit is really big.
It looks so good.
I want to drink beer.
Beer.
Because, I mean, we're drawing...
Yeah,
I mean, illustration deadline and every night I really want
to drink beer, but...
You're too old.
Oh, yes.
Shut up!
How dare you meet?
You know opi.
Don't say that.
You draw me like this!
In foreign say, I like pattern.
Hey, I really want drawing big oppa like me for you.
Oh no, kimoi, kimoi.
Kimoi!
Ladies, kimoi.
Big oppa!
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm waiting one million really.
That's right.
your your obi a change at one million yes change your obi oh
really really big no how big i i will i will drawing not big
just long obi long
long to my toes yes long one 140 centimeter long Oh, fine.
Are we throwing?
Aren't you guys?
Doesn't that make you guys want to subscribe to see the 140
centimeter Yeah, please please subscribe many many I'm scary
I'm more Okay, okay, almost you're tall.
Yeah, almost as tall as me Please buy.
I think this is useful.
Useful?
Yes.
Useful.
Good.
Yes.
Buy it.
This is good for anybody to use.
Everybody can use more cups.
Yes.
I want to use it right now because Tokyo is 40 40 40 degrees
in Tokyo Celsius you guys yeah I really want to use it right
now and this is really half for uh like that's what
It's really a pointy color.
Ice water.
Really helpful.
This is really cute.
This design is really cute.
This is a pet bottle holder.
You guys saw like a water bottle.
Like a koozy.
So it's really cute.
The design is so cute.
And the colors.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It's really pointy color pink.
And mint color is It's really kawaii!
Yeah!
And it looks like it has like some sort of hook.
So...
It's easy to use.
Yeah, yeah.
No, doki-doki-doki!
Doki-doki!
I want, I want this the most.
Actually, yes.
I think the next thing, wait, there's another thing I really
want.
Who?
It's coming up soon.
Oh, tapestry.
Tapestry?
No tapestry?
Yeah, no tapestry.
Oh yes, it's good.
T-shirts, no.
What are we doing?
It went back to the beginning on that.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay, don't worry.
Okay, okay.
Ta-a-a!
Ta-a-a-a!
Sokai!
Sokai.
Refresh?
Like something.
Sokai!
Cooling?
Cooling towel with pouch.
Pouch!
You can get a pouch.
Weight towel.
You can use it.
The poachy!
Pouchy!
Pouchy...
Oh, be- Oh, that's-
That's okay.
I like pouch.
I have so many pouches.
You.
Like, I see, I see.
I see, I see.
I, I don't see.
I see.
Oh, yeah.
I don't really sweat on my face but on my back I'm always
sweating Yeah, don't worry, Aimee I mean Your back Yeah,
it's also so refreshing
Sokai.
Towel.
Get it.
Because, yeah.
Yeah.
When it's summer, having a towel is an important thing to
have, everybody.
Yeah.
Stay cool.
Next.
Yes.
Okay.
This is really helpful to me because she, she, I already
using Luke.
Luke, Luke, like a backpack.
Oh, like a backpack.
Big backpack.
I'm really worried.
No, that is really punk party.
like really what yeah my bag was like overflowing it was so
it was so big yeah i'm right yeah really big and oh taku
will bring like roller bags so this time you you come in
comique yes you bring your backpack again yes Yeah, yes.
Okay.
Maybe rolling bag too.
And you bring to this leather bag, a leather sheet bag, and
you're using, and you find too many Dojin-si Blue Archive.
Yes.
Blue Archive.
I think you, first time you come to Kamike and you look
around another Blue Archive space, Blue Archive booth.
And last, you come my space and mama, I'm coming.
I think you're doing that.
No, no.
Because another space tour, wrong line.
And I first come, came, came, go their space.
Sorry, mom, I think you do that, isn't it?
But your line is also so long.
No.
Oh, mom, you don't have a Kauru stuff.
Oh my god, I don't need your new book.
You say that, isn't it?
No, never, never, never.
I'm really scary about...
Shimiko is also so cute.
You say lie.
You just talk.
Just talk.
Kuchiだけ?
Like, Kuchiake?
Oh, Shimiko, good, but your eyes always searching and
looking.
Koharu or another cute pattern girls isn't it but but I love
Shimiko but can't I love Koharu so much too well I know you
really like Koharu and this time I'm drawing me to a chibi
SD character new one yes yes I mean drawing inspiration from
koalu it's so cute it's so yeah yeah i don't know me to like
that but uh i always mean to uh no koalu stop but mean to uh
oh it's okay i mean mama try to drawing something like koalu
mama draw every everything i mean mama draws is so cute
everybody agree agree no no yes no no is the no not true
it's true you guys saying lie no you guys yeah no no no you
guys really like pattern i mean confused because these 100
years years i mean think about every guys every guys many
guys like big opi, my opinion, but I mean mint, I mean matte
mint and so many people like pattern.
This is really, oh this is really confused.
I mean think about drawing my life.
No, no, we have a phrase in English.
We have phrase about opi.
Any size is a prize.
yeah no no no yes no i think no one like big old bye no
that's not true no really i sometimes i'm drawing mint
they're really scary oh this old boy is okay too small too
small is okay but You guys, what cute!
I cannot understand sometimes, but it's okay.
One million, I'm waiting forever.
140 centimeter.
Centimeter wrong up eye.
I can draw it.
Maybe more.
I'm really curious when I'm drawing wrong up eye.
You guys reaction.
I'm really curious.
Maybe crying.
Oh, there is...
The tears is...
Happiness, happiness tears over something.
I don't know.
Okay.
Yes, next.
Next.
Oh!
Warm and cold.
It can hold your things to be like...
It's like a lunchbox.
It makes it hot.
Lunchbox?
Like hot stuff is hot and cold stuff is cold.
It's cold.
Okay, okay, okay.
This is like a lunchbox.
Lunchbox?
Have you used it?
No.
No?
What?
But in Japan, too many people are using bento.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
I think this is helpful to bento, bento guys.
Actually?
Oh, I used.
But I was a baby.
A baby?
Three, four, five?
Yeah, it's very popular lunchbox for school.
Oh, in me, in me, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in,
It's like an American school, like elementary school.
Oh, elementary school.
Elementary school need bento?
Yes.
Lunchbox from from mama?
Ah, so no.
Not eat pop tart or...
Oh, no, pop tart or orange juice.
I guess it depends on the mama if they pack pop tarts or
not.
Pop tarts is perfect I think.
This time when I went to Ofkai and Komike Deadline is too
busy and I'm drawing it in my hotel room.
That time I'm going to eat a pop tart and burriner and there
is really good and so it's not an American.
Oh, that is, what's that?
That is, what's the most, the normal flavor?
Vanilla-aji-like vanilla?
Was that a vanilla?
Oh yeah.
That's like jam-like something like that.
What was that jam?
Strawberry jam?
Oh, maybe strawberry pop color.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm eating and, oh, yummy.
Yummy.
And...
Yeah, like, dessert?
No.
Yummy.
And...
last two and and and this one ah uh the donuts peach oh yeah
before stream ayami mama was like do you know donuts look
donuts peach donut peach really really amazing i really like
that every day uh i mean eat almost 10 or 15.
i'm sorry I don't know.
It's okay.
I'm searching traders just at the farmer's market.
Where is donut peach?
Where?
I didn't know what she meant.
I thought she meant like a peach ring.
So I was like, are they gummy?
Are they gummies?
But she said, no.
It's like a flat donut.
Sorry, flat peach.
Yeah, so flat peach.
You don't know.
I know.
Don't interested a donut peach.
Why?
That is really good.
In Japan, donut peachy field.
Yeah, some.
Like, there are some, but there are few.
Yeah.
Like, one of the things I'm trying to donut peach.
really oh my god this is really i guess it's hard to get in
japan i want to try i already yeah i already missed uh i
mean left to almost five peachy uh before uh return japan
can i bring on the plane uh inside inside plane okay okay
outside plane uh outside plane is uh it's a danger police
coming okay okay They're almost 10 hour flight, isn't it?
I mean, eat two hours, one peach, I'm eating.
And every peach done.
I mean, kill every donut peach.
Killed?
Oh my god.
Because this time, I mean, buying peach almost 60?
Almost 60, 65?
I'm sorry.
Yes.
one bus best basket one basket almost have pan and i mean
buying six bucks um and eat every day oh my god this is
amazing this time my san francisco san jose san jose
experience is just peach just peach now you guys know what
to bring for ayami mama when she comes back it's a donut
peach please our white pink peach I will bring some because
I think already Japan thinks I'm a criminal that they won't
give me the visa so it doesn't matter if I eat green cream
cream in our mint I'm scared it's okay you can get I think
someday 10 years and you can i'll buy this and i will fill
it with donut peach okay donut peach okay done and last last
one last one
this this you you know this i did not know it before i saw
this But now, this is a bag where you hold your favorite
dojinchi.
And it has a display so you can show off.
It's like a Ita bag.
Yeah, Ita bag.
Yeah, I'm really good.
Oh, oh, this is really ideal item.
This is really.
But I think if someone using this inside my Dojin-Shi, there
is really, wow, amazing and shock and amazing.
And I mean, I mean, talk to him.
Excuse me, can I take photos?
Can I put with you maybe?
This is really amazing.
It's an amazing item.
Yeah.
of this before and now i want it so i can you can use it yes
yeah meat you you buy this and you can uh put in your your
meat loves you yes yes yes yes yes yeah you can put in the
dojin chi my mama maybe yeah loves you in there so i mean
i'm really i'm i'm like oh meat thank you and meat uh bye
turn off my space like my space kind of yeah yeah yeah I
mean watching dad and crying no she's saying I'll go to the
booth with this and have I mean dojinshi in it and I'll say
hi mama i'll give her a greeting and then as soon as i walk
away i switch with koharu don't you should that you should
do that i think oh you do that already i'm really i'm crying
i'm crying but it's okay it will be it will be mint loves
you number two oh yeah please try try try and please take I
need to put some portal.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I want to ask, do you mean to...
Which one is your number one you like?
This is really funny.
I understand.
Okay, this is, I understand.
This is really funny.
And I mean, I mean, like this, number one is pet bottle
holder.
Pet bottle holder is, I think I mean, always, I mean, every
day I can use it because when I Oh, I take a walk.
I take a walk.
Walk time.
Walk.
Oh, English.
It's really good for...
Walk.
I think so too.
I'm excited for everything.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah.
And everybody.
oh also uh there's also that my mama drew they will be
displayed yeah in the yeah display in the
Yeah, kind of like this.
So you can see this is an old one.
Yes, yes.
Now we display inside the vending machine.
This Shikishi.
Please come and take picture and unroll the Twitter, please.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Good drawing.
This one.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah.
You, me, oh, mint one is more cuter.
No, they're both so cute.
Oh, moe, moe.
Oh, good.
Oh, thank you.
But this time, I'm thinking about, I want to get your sign,
autograph in this Shikiji.
But deadline is before the off-kind.
Ah.
Yeah, I mean just drawing my sign.
But please, searching this bending machine and please check.
Check, check.
Push, push, push.
Real, push.
Mindu, can you find it?
I will find it.
There's so many bending machines.
Yeah.
Oh, it will be so cool to see Ayami Mama's art all over
Comic-K.
I'm shy, kill me!
And I know probably there are many people that won't be able
to go to Comic-Cat.
I know it's very, very far.
So I have decided that I will buy many of the goods for you
guys.
And I will host a raffle.
So if you are wanting the Comic-Cat goods, Oh my god, oh my
god!
Can I join?
Can I jump level?
Yeah, you can join.
You can.
Thank you?
Oh my god.
Okay, Aureo, can you move to the countryside?
You have money?
Are you okay?
I saved my money for this.
Aureo, not checking.
Okay.
So we'll wait for more information.
on the raffle.
So sweet me!
I cannot believe!
She always blocked me!
But...
Why are you this time so sweet, your eyeballs?
What?
No, I'm always so nice to them.
Right, everybody.
I'm nice.
You can't believe.
I cannot believe.
Mmmmm.
I can... she is really...
scary girl really because i'm a ghost oh okay i forgot that
okay you ghost oh my god already um this time you really
busy of car in of kai uh i'm really sad that we can uh spend
time uh we can yeah so maybe just but but we probably 30
minutes 30 minutes yes I was too busy and you too yeah this
time really tired the 10 hour flight flight is too too tired
the first day i'm almost asleep and prepared of kai and uh
friday saturday sunday and monday i'm i'm returned to japan
and we can we can talk too many times but it's really
amazing you guys live is really cool and amazing and this
time really i'm really happy and i'm so happy i'm so happy
you're so good singing this time this time and i'm uh
realize again oh yeah okay me too really good singing good
dancing uh pv victoria really really cool too and I'm really
my daughter is great I mean my feeling is thank you thank
you ghost thank you thank you ghost no thank you for for for
drawing me so cute and we're always working so hard you work
very very hard mama and you your illustrations are always so
cute and i'm so proud to be your daughter and your friend
but but i i i
I can support her is just drawing and I want to more draw
mint and I want to make mint more cuter and more cute not
now cute but more cuter and sometimes I want to draw really
broke a bite too and this time i'm really i like uh the new
outfit is really like and thank you oh yes very cute and me
too first uh talk to me i want this outfit that time oh me
too really know uh herself uh
You think so?
Do I know things that suit me, you guys?
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I think I'm no sundress because no money, I just naked nude
beach.
Oh, I mean using nude beach, no sundress.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
You're going together?
You have nude, isn't it?
Do I?
Wait.
You're nude.
There is a secret?
There is secret?
You have...
No way!
No!
No, no.
Sorry, spoil, sorry about...
No, I have bathing suit.
No, no.
sorry it is some some someday someday we can go to a way to
new the beach we can do it we can do with one millionth time
with my 140 centimeter opi yes i already bring to you to the
backside yeah your opi i will bring and don't worry thank
you i will i will i will wear them
excited excited this comic and i'm nervous too uh please
many people come and buy and take photo our illustration
please yes thank you we'll do our best push push yes push
push push Right?
Right?
Oh, I'm scared!
Okay!
Deadline is coming, mate!
Oh, I should go.
You should go work, yes, yes, yes!
Yeah, I mean drawing Shimiko now.
Chimiko!
Oh, everybody look forward to it!
Everyone, everyone come.
Please calm my space too, please.
I'm scared every time, Komike.
Please calm.
I'm scared.
No.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, everybody will calm, right?
No, there will be so many people.
No, you don't calm me!
I calm!
I come, I come.
Me and Ayami together take so many pictures and show you
guys.
So yeah, please looking forward this summer Comic-Con.
Yay!
Sorry guys, I am flying again to Japan.
But I hope you...
I hope you...
I'm not...
Top secret, top secret, okay?
But hopefully you guys understand the reason why.
She's ready this time is like...
Feeling like work..
Work, working, working Uh-uh-uh.
Uh-oh, sure.
Orchikatsu's a nice one.
Orchikatsu 1920.
This is from work.
No, work, uh, Yes, That's all.
I don't know.
Uh-uh, uh-uh, Uh-uh,
so, If I have time, I'll go see idols.
But right now, I have no plan because this is a work trip.
Work trip.
Oh, yes, yes.
I'm scared.
Well, I want to eat something with you this time.
Something you want to eat something?
Unagi!
Unagi?
Oh, so that's what I'm saying.
Is it okay?
Yeah, this is cool.
Unagi is cool.
A little expensive.
Don't worry.
My manager paying.
It's a summer food.
Unagi, Unagi.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a really happy food, isn't it?
Okay, we eat Unagi and take many pictures and showing,
upload Twitter and enjoy.
Comey care.
Please call and showing us, please.
Yes, it is.
Well, there will be more.
information about goods and everything uh we'll post about
it so if you're interested in anything please be on the
lookout um please give your special minto ayami comic cat 50
50 50th comic cat 50th anniversary comic cat goods so it's a
very special occasion yes yes yes yes
I'm nervous.
She's nervous.
Yeah, deadline.
Both do my best and I wish everyone enjoy Komike and Mint
Safe flight.
Yeah, please come faster.
I miss you.
Yay!
we will i saw boy you let's play let's hang out yeah thank
you for it too tired after yeah because the english one hour
english one hour half english really really you can use
really think that i'm 100 years old at using english really
how about the really thank you for listening my bad baby uh
six months in english and really thank you every time and
thank you support me to every time it's really happy to me
and to you in komi kei komi kei Oh, hi.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah, ah, ah.
What?
Ahhh?
That's okay.
I- Don't- I- I cannot talk.
Uh, I cannot talk?
Not yet?
And I think mean to I mean...
Come again.
Come again?
Yeah!
She's looking forward to our something.
Hi, in future too.
Hi, thank you.
What?
Kibitsu.
Hi, um, please enjoy me too tight too.
Hi, don't.
Futomomo.
My thighs.
Oh, yes.
Enjoy, enjoy my thighs.
Oh, yeah.
She is tight too.
Oh, oh no, oh no!
Why are you so weird?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you!
Otsu ayaminto na na?
Ayaminto?
Otsu ayaminto?
Okay.
Otsu ayamintu!
Otsu ayaminto!